- On this episode,
we do a midnight
session in a ballpark.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 253
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
And we are here in AT&amp;T Park,
San Francisco with
Alexis and Hunter Pence.
- That's right.
- Alexis.
- We did it, we got you here.
- Yes you did.
- We are, thank
you for being here.
- He was willing to
come, this is awesome.
- That's true, you were willing.
Thank you for being here.
- Your welcome.
So Alexis, why
don't you tell everybody,
you know it's really
funny, Hunter, obviously
you're a very
famous baseball player
and we'll get into
that in a little bit.
Brandon, my best friend
is gonna read the questions
and Hunter, Brandon has you
on his fantasy team right now
and tried to trade me you
during the Minor League Draft
for a draft pick of
mine, but I held off
and did not trade a
draft pick for you so,
you're gonna have to
take that for the way it is.
- A couple games
you're gonna pay for that.
- I'm gonna try
to buy low right now.
Brandon's out of it.
- You might want to
hit me, you might want to
keep it up, my low.
- He's gonna dump
you in a couple weeks.
- Alright, that's cool, I know.
- But what's really interesting
to me Vayner Nation is Alexis
is actually very
much in our world.
- Yes.
- YouTube vlogger
and more importantly,
and I want to talk
about this a little bit
before we get
into the questions.
You are a real gamer.
- Yes.
- You have a Twitch channel.
- I do.
- So why don't you tell the
Vayner Nation a little bit
about yourself then and
a little bit about that.
- Yeah, well I vlog on
YouTube, Lets Get Lexi,
you guys want to
follow it, subscribe
and there I do specialty
coffee shop reviews with Hunter
when we travel and I do a lot
of the day in the life ofs
'cause we live this crazy life.
- As in travel the cities
during the baseball season.
- We travel the city,
we move three times a year
and I show what
it's like to actually be
in the baseball world.
We're like these
traveling gypsies,
sort of like you, you know.
- I get it.
- And, yeah and I show that
and then I also
Twitch stream, twitch.tv/--
- And what are
you playing right now,
oh I'm sorry, go ahead.
- Oh yeah,
twitch.tv/letsgetlexi.
- DRock, edit that up.
- Yeah, put that in there.
- Link the shit up.
- And right now I'm
playing Kingdom Rush,
I really love this game,
it's a tower defense game,
but we play anything from Smash.
Hunter comes on, Hunter also
has his own twitch stream
and I stream, I try to
stream two times a week,
like I said and I
go for hours when I do.
And I stream Smash,
I stream Kingdom Rush,
I'm always looking for
new games, Cities Skyline,
I love anything strategy.
- You were telling me while
we were watching the game,
that you were a
gamer when you were a kid
but then in high school,
college you stopped,--
- I stopped.
- 'Cause it wasn't that cool.
- You gotta do the girl thing.
- Girls aren't
supposed to do it, yeah.
- In your early days,
what were you playing,
like Super Mario?
- I was playing
Super Mario, yeah, so like
when I was growing
up, my parents were like
what is this gaming?
Like it wasn't...
- Sure.
- You know like when it
first came out they were like
we don't want you to do this.
All you're doing is
sitting in front of the TV
and so I would say the
first game I really got into
was something called
Bass Masters Classic.
- Oh my god, I remember that.
- That's actually kind of fun.
- Yeah, SNES, we got an
SNES and I bought the game
because I had to
replay it now and I was like,
I can't believe I played this
game for as long as I did.
That, and what was another one?
Tiny Toon Adventures.
- I gotta throw some super
street cred her way though,
so we get to sometimes
get to do little events
with different gaming
companies and they'll mail me
the show, it's like awesome.
- Yeah.
- And we challenge all
of the people that work
at these gaming
companies in Smash Bros...
- And you dominate?
- And Alexis is nasty,
they don't even know it,
so like whenever
we get into these...
- Yeah they think I'm just like,
come in, just like you know.
- A girl.
- A girl, I don't know.
- We come in and like rip shop.
- It would be awesome.
- I hear you're a
pretty legit player as well.
- I'm a gamer, like
through and through.
- He is.
- Like so when
you're done with baseball,
are you thinking
about going into,
like are you going to
have a double athletic career?
- Yes.
- Well I don't know if I'm
going to be a professional gamer
'cause they're incredibly
talented and on next level.
- Yes, but what are you best at?
- At which game?
- Yeah.
- I'm the best at all,
whichever I put my mind to,
I'm really good at.
- It's insane, I'm telling you.
- Like there was at time when
I could have been professional
at World of Warcraft,
not that it's like
a professional thing.
- [Alexis] It is
- Well it is.
- Sort of.
- [Alexis] No definitely.
- There was a time...
- Yeah like don't
dis, WoW. (laughing)
- I would've been
involved in potentially,
is like I love twitch streaming
but I love tournaments.
- Yeah.
- So I'm hoping to run
tournaments where we're opening
a coffee shop that's
going to be like coffee shop,
board games, I love
Magic the Gathering.
- New media, yeah.
- Did you collect
Magic Gathering cards?
- I play sealed and
drafts, so I have them.
- Just to collect,
what a question.
- It is nerding up
here in San Francisco,
of course, I grew up
selling all this crap
to dudes like you.
Alright, let's go
into the first question.
- [Voiceover] Andrew Conner
asks, "How will professional
"sports change in
the next 10 years?"
- How will professional sports
change in the next 10 years?
Alexis.
- Hmm, I mean I think
there's gonna be a lot,
a bigger, with eSports
pretty much, I think eSports
is gonna be just a you
know, a big competitor,
if not bigger to baseball,
football, to the normal
main stream
sports that we know now.
I just think that we're
gonna consider it just as big
of a sport,
eSports, anything in eSports
like fighting games
and all that stuff.
- Hunter.
- Yeah, I definitely think
eSports is gonna grow huge
'cause kids and I think
that the live streaming of it
is gonna be a big deal.
- Yep.
- And I think you
said it pretty much like
your phones are the new TV.
- 100%.
- Yeah.
- It's gotten faster.
They're making
great changes in baseball
and the sports like
football, basketball...
- Yeah, they'll
all still be around,
I just think it's gonna be...
- They're gonna
grow but I think eSports
is growing to be on that level.
- Yeah.
- It's just, it's so
fun to see a live event.
- 100%.
I'm gonna add that I
think soccer will continue
to propel the Latino
population in the U.S.
I think soccer,
especially with the World Cup
coming to North America,
and I also think UFC
will continue
to grow and I think
that there'll be
something 10 years from now
that none of us
are thinking about.
- I hope it's
croquet, 'cause I might
have a career in
croquet. (laughs)
- I'm gonna go not croquet.
It might be like
slime-making or like...
But I genuinely
believe that in 10 years,
there'll be something emerging.
It won't be mainstream.
It'll be like eSports
today, 10 years from now,
something that
we can't think of.
The biggest thing I remind
people is that in 1955,
baseball players literally
had jobs during the off-season
in hardware stores
to make ends meet.
The heavyweight
champion of the world
in boxing was the
most famous person.
Horse racing was
on a huge pedestal,
and professional
football was a joke,
like it was a
nonexistent situation.
So, things always,
always continue to change.
- It's not terribly long, like--
- That's right.
That's right, Brandon?
- [Voiceover] Michelle's Mat asks,
"What's the one dream
career you would have wanted
"if you weren't
doing what you are now?"
- Alexis, the one dream career--
- I'm doing what I'm doing.
This is an easy question
I'm doing what I'm doing.
- But if there was
anything else you could do?
- There isn't.
I'm literally doing
what I wanna be doing.
Yeah, I mean, unless I could
maybe cohost a show with Oprah.
That would be my one dream job.
- Okay, well that's
a good answer. Hunter?
- You know,
baseball's pretty dang good.
It's pretty awesome.
- When did you wanna
become a baseball player?
- About seven years old.
- Wow!
- I remember one
time asking my dad.
I was like, "Dad, I wanna
be a major leaguer," right?
And he was like, "I just
hope you make it to college,"
and I was devastated.
(all laughing)
- You're like, "I hate you dad!"
Nah, I'm kidding,
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- What, of course
I'm gonna make it.
- Did you have siblings?
- I did.
I have a brother
and three sisters.
- And was your
brother older or younger?
- Older.
- And was he good at baseball?
- Yeah.
- He was great at baseball.
- He made it to--
- He made it to the
minors, like high A.
He blew out, he ended up
having like a Tommy John.
- Yeah.
- It's his son that throws,
what does he throw, 56?
- Yeah, at seven?
- His kids are all
really good ball players.
- Yeah, it's insane.
- It's crazy.
- Yeah, maybe to own the Jets.
- Yeah, my answer is definitely
to be the quarterback of the
New York Jets, so I could
take control of the situation
and win seven Super Bowls.
Once I realized, unlike Hunter,
around 4th grade,
I realized I was more likely
to own the Jets
than to play for them,
and that's what I've
been focused on since.
- I love it.
- Brandon?
- [Voiceover] Blake Masters asks,
"How many coaches tried
to change your mechanics
"and how important was it
to stay true to yourself?"
- Well, I guess this
one's for you, Hunter,
so we'll just stand over here.
- Yeah, yeah!
- All right, Hunter,
how many coaches have tried
to change your
mechanics through the years?
- Pretty much every one of 'em.
- You gotta stand closer.
- The fact is I tried
to change my mechanics
with whatever they
teach me, and it's just
I don't really have the ability,
like the flexibility,
like I'm trying to do what,
like feel versus real is
a weird thing in baseball.
You feel like
you're doing one thing,
but you're really
not, and so, you know,
I just, whatever way they
put me, like I've done stuff
like down here, up
here, like I've done it all.
(all laughing)
- All right, Brandon,
let's keep it going.
That was an easy one.
- [Voiceover] Ivan Bickett
asks, "Gentlemen,
"in honor of Mother's Day,
what is the number one way
"your spouses have
helped you succeed?"
- Oh.
- Oh, I really
like this question.
- You like this question, right?
Actually, let's start this way.
- Oh!
- Yeah, how
about you answer that?
- I mean, obviously,
Hunter's presence is huge,
so that's helped me get kind
of a jump off a platform.
But also, Hunter is just super
supportive off camera, too.
I really didn't believe
that I could do it on my own,
but he's made me believe
that I can and I'm doing it.
And even though I'm
still in the beginning stages,
he still encourages
me just as much
on my first day as
whatever day I'm on now.
He's pushed me
through some pretty hard times
where I do want to
give up, and I'm like,
"Ah, YouTube,"
but then here I am
and I still have
a passion for it,
and I think he reminds me
of what I want in the end.
- Here we are talking
to one of your favorite
social media people ever,
living the dream right now.
- I mean, this
is insane, you guys.
I was telling
our friend earlier,
as Gary was watching
the game, and I was like,
"This is a surreal moment
that Gary is here."
I never thought
you'd be here in real life.
- Real life.
(Alexis laughs)
- So I read a lot of different
things, like mental things,
psychology things,
spiritual things,
and I'm always
studying to get better.
She's wonderful to
bounce things off with
and she is so good
at me not taking it
so seriously and
being so hard on myself.
She's helped me.
Like I'm a whole new
person because she's taught me
not to take myself so seriously,
and she'll remind me
when I'm really down.
She'll be like,
"You've always said you have
"to be carefree and
you have to let go."
And so she like frees my spirit,
where when I get into this funk
where I tie
myself up, I can let go.
- Do you...
Is it a situation
where you'll get wound up
when you're in a
hitting slump, more so?
Like fielding is kind of
a different thing, right?
Like it's at the plate,
where you're, you know,
is that where you're
getting into like a rut
and you start overthinking it?
- Yeah well you
just get into ruts where,
like, you're not
even if you're hitting good,
if you're not
getting timely hits
or the hits or the
team's not winning.
- Sure, there's
a lot of variables.
- And I feel like you
find your greatest success
when you can like,
almost cut yourself
off of like result oriented
and be like
attitude, preparation
like everything is in tune.
I wanna be completely prepared,
I wanna have fun
and I'm gonna have the attitude
and expectation like
that I'm gonna get this done.
- For me it's pretty simple,
you know, Lizzie,
it's unbelievable to
be able to live a life
where you're not
worried about the other person.
You know it's really
funny how I have Brandon here.
I would say that I have
three clear people in my life
that have done that for me:
My mom, Brandon,
and my wife Lizzie,
which is literally
knowing 100% that
that person's intent is pure
and I never have to
worry about their reactions.
Which almost makes
you take them for granted.
You know the biggest thing.
- Right.
- You know Lizzie an I have
been married now for 13 years
and like I'm always worried
to even take her for granted
'cause she makes it so easy.
And I travel a lot
and we very much have
an old school marriage
where it's divide
and conquer, right?
- Right, right.
- I'm working,
she's taking at home,
which is not the
politically correct thing
in today's 2017 world.
- Right.
- But we're aligned
and I guess she just
allows me to breathe easily,
which has an enormous impact.
You know I grew up
like any competitive,
kind of A-type,
which is like when you're 15, 14
you don't realize
like what a spouse
that supports you--
- Really does.
- actually means.
You know I look at a
lot of my contemporaries
people I compete
with in business,
or on my team and
they don't have that
that lack of
stress on their chest.
They're overthinking things.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- They, they're
dragged down because at home--
- It's a freedom.
- It's a freedom
that you can't, yes,
and I think that's
definitely something that we--
- Power.
- Yeah.
- You're so good at it.
- Yeah, so are you.
- You guys should high
five again. That was really--
- I'm all about it.
- Yeah!
I love it!
(Gary laughs)
Last one Brand?
Is this the last one?
- [Brandon] Last one.
- Go ahead, who is it?
- [Brandon] Noelani asks--
- Who?
- [Brandon] Noelani.
- Noelani. Okay
Sorry sorry. Noelani.
- Noelani.
Who?!
Noelani.
- [Voiceover] Noelani asks,
"If you could tell
your high school senior self
"only one thing from the future
"what would it be?"
- What would you have told
your high school senior self
one thing for the future.
- Oh man.
One thing,
it would probably be
to listen less to what
people have to say
and do what you want.
Do what you want
and don't be
afraid to want to do it.
Even if it's
something so stupid.
Just do it.
Just go and do it.
- Yeah I would just--
- Hunter?
- I would probably just
like tell my senior self like
"Believe in yourself more."
'Cause I was, I was
like super hard work.
Like it was all about the work
and I never thought
I was doing enough
and sometimes
I almost over did it,
where I would just be like
"Hey, believe in yourself,
trust the process."
- I would have said listen Gary,
"I've got some
great fuckin' news,
"you're gonna be a 100% right.
"It is all actually gonna happen
"and you're going to
prove them all wrong."
- Hell yeah!
- I mean that's
what happened I was,
Brandon knows, Brandon
and I were literally in
the bottom 25 of
our entire class.
Like we were shit students.
Like Brandon was terrible
and I made him look
like an honor roll student.
- Really?
- Yeah I was a
really bad student.
- What was your
plan at the time?
- To fucking dominate
and buy the Jets.
Like I knew I was
an entrepreneur
long before it was cool.
- Oh okay.
- Like we were making money,
like we were selling stuff.
Like we were in a
different head space
and I just knew it.
And I think for
everybody who's watching like,
that inside voice,
I totally agree like who
would have thought back then
that gaming would
be main stream.
Right like--
- Yeah.
- Like, like it's--
- You hid it, you hid that,
you wouldn't
tell anyone you gamed.
- No.
- No, of course not.
And so like really understand--
- Especially as a
female I'd be like--
- Especially.
- Just no.
- Yeah and so for me,
for me I think the
question there to bring value
to everybody who is watching
and wrapping up is
you know you can always settle
into the norm.
- Yeah.
- Like when you're 18, if
you're under 30 right now,
you have so much time
for the rest of your life.
You can always get the safe job.
You can always go back.
You can never be
back at this place
where you can take high risks
and do your thing and so
I encourage it tremendously.
- Yeah.
- [All] Go for it.
- I like it.
- Alright Alexis,
we're going to let you
ask the question of the day.
Whatever you'd like,
hundreds of comments.
- I know.
- On Facebook and YouTube.
What's your question of the day?
- What gets you to subscribe?
- Oh, I like that!
- That's what I want to know.
- You went with
a real right hook.
- I did. (laughs)
I want real answers!
- You want real,
you want real insight!
- What is it that
makes you want to subscribe?
- Subscribe, yeah.
- I love it!
- Yeah I wanna
hear from all you guys,
like what makes you want to
subscribe to people anywhere,
on anything, on any platform.
- Hunter, toughest pitcher
you faced in your career?
Little baseball inside talk.
Your perspective.
- Tim Lincecum in his hay day.
- Wow, Timmy, cause
of the hair was floppin'?
- He was throwing 100
and it was just running in
and it was a curve ball
he threw me a right handed
left handed curve ball.
- You were just
like, "What the fuck?"
- He was nasty.
- Yeah, my man.
- Thank you so much Gary.
- My pleasure.
- Gary thank you for being here!
- So good to have you.
- This was awesome!
- Yeah this was awesome!
- You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)